«Typisch Guatemala an Hugo ist das Thema
mit der Agenda oder die Terminplanung.
Da ist er natürlich spontan
und er schaut einfach mal.
Und trotzdem muss ich sagen:
Er schafft es immer wieder.
Auch wenn er Leute einlädt, und ich denke,
wir sind zu spät, das reicht nicht mehr.
Es funktioniert immer! Alles!
Das ist eben auch typisch Guatemala.»
«Typisch Schweiz an meiner Frau ist: ...
... Sie ist sehr ordentlich.
Und sie arbeitet viel.»
«Das war in Guatemala, 2004.
Ich war auf einer längeren Reise
durch Zentralamerika.
Dort habe ich Tanzkurse genommen,
weil ich sehr gerne tanze.
Die Tanzlehrerin hiess Gloria und
sie war eine Koryphähe in Antigua.
Einmal sagte sie zu mir:
Wenn du heute noch etwas wartest, ...
... kommen noch zwei Kollegen vorbei,
und wir können noch Rueda tanzen ...
... in der Gruppe.
So kamen dann Hugo und
Jorge, sein bester Freund vorbei, ...
... und so haben wir uns kennen gelernt.
Seit diesem Tanz damals,
sind wir zusammen.»
«Sie hat nebenan in einem Hotel gewohnt, ...
... und plötzlich sagte sie,
gehen wir zu dir nach Hause ...
... und wohnen zusammen.
Das war sehr speziell.
Es war sofort ein Vertrauen da.»
«Es war eine starke Verbindung da.
Sehr speziell: Am anderen Ende der Welt ...
... jemanden zu finden, mit dem man sich
von Beginn weg so nahe ist.»
«Es gab manchmal sehr
schwierige Trennungen.
Beim Abschied wussten wir oft nicht,
wann wir uns wiedersehen.
Damals wussten wir beide noch
nicht, was daraus wird ...
... oder wie das weiter gehen soll.
Wir spürten einfach sehr stark:
Loslassen geht nicht!»
«Meistens koche ich.
Ich koche meistens am Montag ...
... dienstags auch. Ja, meistens.»
«Es wurde dann das wichtigste Thema
gegen Heimweh: Das Essen.
Diese Gerüche zu haben. Also
Koriander, Avocado, Tortillas.
Mittlerweile kann man das alles
auch in der Schweiz kaufen.
Es kommt dem Essen
in Guatemala sehr nahe.»
«Ich habe sehr viel gelernt.
Ich habe mich vom Gedanken befreit, ...
... dass wir immer wissen, wie es läuft
und wie man's macht.
Nein, wir wissen es nicht.
Ein anderer sieht es
vielleicht total anders, ...
... und es funktioniert auch.
Es hat meinen Horizont erweitert, ja.»